l'autre grand titre de l'actualité de ce
lundi c'est la disparition d'yves saint
laurent le créateur et couturier mort la
nuit dernière à l'âge de 71 ans emporté
par un cancer du cerveau du monde entier
les réactions affluent pour saluer le
départ de l'un des plus grands artistes
français
un homme qui a libéré les femmes
révolutionné la mode et marqué son temps
sa mine gorny une des dernières
apparitions publiques d'yves saint
laurent
au milieu de ces fantômes de robes et
pour cette âme tourmentée l'infinie
tristesse de ne plus pouvoir c'est
qu'est ce qui vous rend triste de ne
plus travailler s'ils ont déjà qu'il
avait tourné la page avec ce défilé
d'adieu à beaubourg en chansons dans les
larmes et l'émotion
un choix délibéré fermer la maison de
couture créée 40 ont plutôt devenue un
empire du luxe
comment oublier ses adieux déchirants à
la grande scène de la mode
ce n'est pas sans déchirement que je la
quitte
car je sais bien et les plus beaux
habits sont ceux pour la fête la fin
d'un règne absolu sur la couture
depuis ce 30 janvier 58 ou succédant à
christian dior à l'âge de 21 ans ce
jeune homme timide venu d'oran devient
le plus jeune couturier du monde
cessions d'or m'a écouté votre fille le
seul garçon
ok je puisse avoir vraiment confiance et
qui peut me succéder paris s'extasie
paris cryogénie quatre ans plus tard
avec l'aide de pierre bergé l'ami de
toujours
il ouvre sa propre maison avec une
obsession habillé l'époque je crois que
c'est la plus importante chez un
couturier c'est d'avoir un style qui
soit bien à lui et qui se reconnaissent
un style reconnaissable entre mille
du noir il va faire une vraie couleur il
invente la garde-robe de la femme
moderne
il impose le caban le trench et la
saharienne et surtout le tailleur
pantalon et le smoking reconduit dans
chacune de ses collections
une vraie révolution
je n'aime pas le pantalon lorsqu'il est
portée d'une façon revendicatrice et à
dire je suis l'égal de l'homme aux côtés
georges sand suffragettes je n'aime pas
ça du tout je pense qu'au contraire une
en portant pantalon une fameux peut
développer son maximum de féminité il
impose sur le podium les beautés noires
à sa manière il accompagne la libération
des moeurs chanel revendiquer la liberté
qu'elle avait donné aux femmes et saint
orens leur a donné le pouvoir
saint laurent l'ami des plus grands
artistes comme warhol un esprit libre et
provocateur il fut le premier à défiler
pour la fête de l'humanité le premier à
poser mieux pour un parfum au goût de
scandale le premier offrira deux
milliards de téléspectateurs
le plus grand défilé rétrospective du
monde le premier est rentrée de son
vivant musée auprès des peintres qu'il a
si souvent célébrés 65 la robe mondrian
ou le principe du tawaf très adapté à
une robe de jersey plus tard il y eu des
collections van gogh braque matisse des
peintres qui selon sue consoler ce génie
mélancolique des collections
c'est souffrir énormément en dehors des
grandes joies
c'est vraiment malheureux j'avais jamais
confiance en moins chaque condition et
qui est une obsession
à 9 ans il n'a d'yeux saint laurent
avait juré qu'il aurait un jour son nom
en lettres de feu sur les champs elysées
rêve exaucé pour cet artiste peu doué
pour le bonheur qu'ils avaient choisi
comme signature un coeur la plus belle
parure des femmes les bras de l'homme
qu'elle aime disait-il pour les autres
heureusement je suis là